this is a production of Cornell
University
I'm really delighted to be here today
this first slide just shows a few go the
Garden staff that we have it's a very
small staff so I was explaining for this
morning that there's one gardener for
vegetables one for flowers one for
native plants and one for fruit so and
we have a few helpers that two people in
the center where helpers um until
recently so we try to make this go
forward okay so you might wonder what a
gardener thinks about when they're
gardening
every day eight hours a day and so I got
thinking about how Jefferson's plants
really kind of fuse three three or more
different climatic areas and he kind of
brings them to the kitchen and become
the origin of southern foodways more or
less is starting at Monticello as well
as other places so that's the topic of
my talk today haven't been to Monticello
the garden is a thousand feet long and
it's on its own Terrace the main house
you can see up is uphill and then
Jefferson in 1806 started having us
seven slaves to dig out the mountainside
to make this beautiful Terrace for the
garden it's about two acres long and
it's a UNESCO World Heritage Site the
whole place because of so many so many
activities that Jefferson was involved
in and it's a real hub for for new
thought and enlightenment era so here's
the the garden when you are descending
the steps you can see the terrace
this is a West this is when the Sun is
sinking in the West it's actually a very
south-facing garden and it has this bank
that is acts as a thermal mass the
design of the garden is in squares the
squares have grass paths between so that
you can access the garden when it rains
because it's clay soil that gets really
compacted we have 98 percent compaction
after construction so and the dimensions
are exactly what Jefferson had and my
goal is to grow all the plans that
Jefferson had as well if I can determine
what they are so this is our putting
this because we did have archeology in
the garden
on the bank at one point and up in the
upper left you can see that image is
sketch that Jefferson made of the Garden
Bank in steps so that you'd have these
thorny bushes placed along the bank I
think maybe to stop erosion or animals
he calls it the auditory and that's a
fascinating word because all our ACA is
in are so many botanical names and it
means it comes from the from the kitchen
garden from the veg it's a vegetable if
you ever see a fish analysis on the name
it's more or less a medicinal plant so
and that it comes from that Latin word
which means pot herb or vegetable so
Devon Floyd is standing there next to
this clay bank and you can see that he
actually when they go back to the
original soil in the bank they can find
these steps that were designed by
Jefferson and that rock conglomeration
there that is actually at the base and
it seems like maybe in Jefferson's day
there really was erosion this is not a
faced stone wall this is just stacked in
there kind of like let's get this thing
from stopped from collapsing and if you
if I go back you can see it's a 45
degree angle today and we Jefferson's
day it would have had an extra six feet
of garden space and the the wall is
actually 70 degrees it's almost vertical
so I would love to have that but it's
impractical and they've only excavated
this certain little area where they
intended to put pipes through the garden
they haven't done the rest of the with
the wall I really wanted them to find
glass I really wanted a you know cold
frame but you didn't happen for me so so
Jefferson's garden this huge area it's
two acres was always intended as an
experimental laboratory and he's trying
on all kinds of plants everything he can
find if he hears anything in a newspaper
he writes a letter said send me that
cucumber send me that gourd I want to
try it here he wants to try and find
which two are the best in to grow in
Virginia and so he also of course takes
these things to the kitchen there's a
picture of the garden this spring I grow
a lot of tomatoes this year because
we're making a tomato jam but we grow
them all up on poles so here and there
you'll see a little method
um one example is this Texas bird pepper
someone sends it to him from Texas and
so that's the only reason he has it is
somebody sent it and at the hot weather
plant it's from and he says right there
if it's hardy enough for our climate
then it'll live so he's thinking about
climate all of his his whole life so
this is a kind of choke pins really tiny
so in his life in his lifetime he has a
huge list of things you'd see 48 kinds
of beans 15 kinds of broccoli so not all
of these are specifically identified as
varieties like we have today because
they didn't have the technical mom clay
Chur in this day it was developing and
he has things from friends or he's
calling something forward which might
mean it grows earlier or faster so I try
my best to figure out what all these
things mean and then so far well this
year I had 230 vegetables and herbs and
last year I had like 250 years I'm kind
of a short year so you can see there
have some unusual things and at the end
I'll show you some plants with a little
plant quiz so in 1774 Hebrews 7 kinds of
pumpkins and if you have a garden how
many of you have ever owned seven kinds
of pumpkins like so he did have space
along the river to try these out so I'm
always looking for that black pumpkin
what could that be what is a black
pumpkin so we do have the sweet potato
pumpkin we can grow marina Dukey oh yeah
that's the zookie de Pescatore if you
read Italian books then it's that knobby
that that green worded and they are
still growing it and it's so cool to
find to really nail something down I
grow the white bow or pumpkin as azúcar
Bianchi because it's from the 1600s and
the Boers had great gardens in South
Africa and possibly you know he had it
so I kind of have these leaps faith so
Jefferson was keeping weatherdata his
whole his whole life and he came climate
is one of the sources of great essential
enjoyment I don't know how many of you
would agree with that statement but he
wants everybody to take whether he has
this idea that we need to gather this
and make up a nationwide index of
climate and so
every morning he rises and he takes the
temperature at 4:00 p.m. a takes the
temperature and he gathers this data for
his whole life you can see in
Philadelphia he's gathering it if he
leaves Virginia he asks somebody to take
they take the data for him and so here's
surance insurance of data and so he he
also wants the appearance of birds of
frost the bleeping out of trees all of
this phenological data which is so
important and so valuable to us and then
when Lewis and Clark goes west he wants
all of these data there not only are
they taking a boat West but they have to
observe temperature frost wind chime of
flowering plants and then when he goes
to Europe he has the Virginians back
home to keep the data some of them do I
think Madison does and then he has this
really cool thing but I recommend to a
lot of people who have new Gardens he
says take a thimble every Monday and
plant a thimble full of lettuce in your
garden and he says from February to
September and seat down below that is
and you go through the summer and so now
today we know lettuce will not germinate
at over 85 degrees in the ground it's
gonna be dormant but in his day they
didn't take soil temperature but you can
see that he's going to establish
spring planting times and fall planting
times just because of the failures and
if you look in the book and it says
fails to mature fails to come up I think
those are actually opportunities to
figure out what is going on and so I
never have considered Jefferson ever
really thinking he's failing in anything
it's like this didn't work why didn't it
work this is this is a leap into what I
can figure out how it's been how to make
it work for me and so he has this
gardening calendar and he could see a
February 1st he's putting out oh that
was very good stuff with cover 15 so the
peas lettuce finishing celery when he
starts out as a young man a 1767
planting his garden he's planting
lettuce in May and as soon as I saw that
I thought no that's wrong and so it may
is way too hot for lettuce by the time
he gets to this calendar which is 1824
he's figured out that he has a really
early planning date for these things or
it's going to be too hot and Virginia to
do it because he's coming from maybe his
ancestry is Scottish and it's like cold
weather plants he's got to figure out
with a climate for Virginia to do
so this is really cool we follow we
follow this schedule if we don't have
peas in Lincoln's birthday we won't have
we won't have seeds so plants will
perish without producing seeds for us so
so then he always has the phenology of
things so serious this is for this is a
Rocky Mountains calendar but you can
actually make this with your own
calendar but we know when flea beetles
are that when the red buds are blooming
will have flea beetles in the garden
it's just synchronous so this is a
calendar from because it was convenient
to put in it's not really from Virginia
but you can make one of these yourself
if you keep data in a little notebook
and so he almost has the growing degree
Denny thing I think because he's got all
the data he's got the high and low
temperatures each day and growing degree
days when he added together and and
divide it by two and so if a pea comes
up you start your growing degree day
calculations
I think it's 338 days you'd have two
leaves on the pea so I'm hoping one day
to go back through all those charts and
figure out his growing tree today's
versus our growing degree days would not
be terrific but he's almost got it he's
almost there
it's really fascinating so here he is um
he also gets these foods from different
climates and so he's got of course the
enslaved or bringing foods from Africa
and West Indies he's got his own salad
bowl you know culture and he's got the
Native American foods that arrived with
the Lewis and Clark expedition this is
one of the examples of a cold weather
northern European kind of crop that's
really technical to grow because this is
sea kale how many of you know the sea
kale or you do cool well so it grows on
the beach and the culture back then was
like the beach would cover it with with
the gravel and you dig it out and it
would be light-colored well we have sea
kale pots you can see a pot nearby you
cover the plant when it's merging and
you get this beautiful yellow stalks
Jefferson in his day they would have
potted them up bringing them inside and
forced them all winter this is a this is
not an easy thing to grow this is not a
you know just throw the seeds in and
have a beter carrot so today we have
centers of origin and I was really
pleased to see that you have that kind
of demonstration at the plantations so
you have certain plants came from
certain climates and if you can figure
out where they're from then you can grow
them at the right time of year
especially in Virginia we have a like a
10 month growing season you can just
plug things in at the right time and
then will flourish so that's a really
cool thing so I've got this picture with
the castor beans because you can see
that they're from I think over there on
the African center of origin and there's
payments and Cotton's from South America
and over here yes flex and so forth from
there Eastern so there's no flex in this
picture but you this is a picture taking
like two days ago
in the garden we haven't had any frost
yet so and here's again here's some
peppers from South America and said it's
arrived so we have a lot of North
American crops not many Chinese crops
for us yeah that's a great question
because actually the food that was on
the ships to feed them were their native
foods and that's how a lot of these
things came to us and I'll show you a
couple of those and in a second so
Jefferson went to Paris to be he had
various civic civic duties there but I
wanted to show you what Paris looked
like and this is 1792 all of the green
areas if you brew into Paris lately they
notice that those green areas are
probably not any green any longer but in
the corner is his over there this is his
house this is his vegetable garden and
when I saw when I saw that image I
thought what was he growing in that
garden dad is enormous all the rest is
like pleasure gardens with trees and he
has its tables over there and then
everything around him is Gardens
so he really I think has a lot of
influence from his Paris is Paris
experience so this little list in the
book it was a letter Frances Epps was
his uh his relative ease since these
seeds back to bridge
from all these different things there's
like I think four kinds of cauliflower
like five kinds of peas you can see the
whole list and so that's fascinating to
me I wanted to grow the Paris garden so
then the things that he's missing when
he's in Paris are the things at the
bottom of sweet potatoes and corn and
watermelons those things aren't impacted
so I thought that was fascinating that's
the real Virginian over there wishing he
had you know some hominy so I we did
grow a garden Paris in the 17 of the
1786 era and you can see we have some
cauliflowers cabbages this pea it was
really proud that to actually find this
pea he calls the Dourif grapey of
holland for frames and we actually
through some research and look through
all these old books and it's actually
the de grâce sugar pea that you can get
from Baker Creek seeds and it grows
beautifully and so to me if I grow
something that I think is what he's
talking about and it grows wonderfully
and maybe if he's grown at a couple
years that must be it most likely is
what he had I don't think he keep
growing something that doesn't grow well
so anyway that's that's really a good
thrill and so does he so um he meets and
ra2 in and they had the same basically
the same lifespan which is very
interesting he - in two years before
Jefferson and he had the Jardin des
Plantes
which is called the Jardin du Roi about
them so they exchanged have a seen
exchange and andrea is sending up to 700
different seeds for things every year
big box would come finally one year when
that box didn't come he said what
happened to Henry's box and he had died
so there was said but they had a huge
exchange and Jefferson sends all kinds
of trees to him so I suppose you could
find out if we had any any descendants
over there or not but that was one place
where he got seeds another influence was
Philip Metz I who was from Italy
Philip was an amazing guy who was here
to establish a wine company and some
agricultural interests and became
friends with Jefferson and mitts I
starts to establish the vineyards for
Jefferson and he brings over ten Italian
gardeners many of them remained in the
Charlottesville area and
today and in all of us of course in the
Paris era all of his journal references
are in French and now all of the journal
references are in Italian Philip is
there so we still we see we have these
vineyards today and you can notice the
sort of rough wooden structures that are
really difficult to take care of and
anyway we have 22 varieties that they
attempted to grow on the on the left
side and on the upper side is ascender
of a sea grapes that we can harvest for
wine so what was interesting about
filament zai is that if you look at the
the kind of a fuzzy picture but if you
look at the latitude between Virginia
which is sort of like in this little
dent here and you look over to where
Philip was from Italy they kind of match
so he's kind of on the same latitude and
we actually looked at the ethnobotany of
Philips area and found salad Burnet for
one thing he calls it Salvas Strela to
pisa and what is that and it's like it
sounds like burnett and we looked in
there and we found it and yes it's salad
Burnet so he's growing it really early
on and so some of these things we kind
of can nail down by looking at that if
you don't have brought it over so and
then Jefferson also travels in Italy
while he's in Paris and he finds olive
trees that are six feet diameter it's
amazing he sees wine growing Parmesan
cheese macaroni mold and it's not them
it's not molding it's a press that you
can make macaroni from and then rice and
silk and he tries to steal rice there's
a great famous story that you can look
online and read about how he's in upland
Italy with with his donkey driver and
they go to this rice patch and he really
wants a certain kind of upland rice and
he says to the farmer can I take a bag
of rice home I mean a 50-pound bag of
rice when I introduced it to South
Carolina and says no now we have this
regional they still have this a regional
rule you can't take things away from
certain regions in Italy says no you
can't so Jefferson says okay can I have
a little bag of it I'll put it in my
pocket
okay you can have a bag of it tells a
donkey driver you take a bag of it too
and if you go across the border you can
get killed for having this rice but they
get it and then they brings it back to
South Carolina and they said you know
people in South Carolina said you know
we have this rice that would really like
better there now I washed I'll tell you
another rice during a second so I want
to mention about food and how because
you don't understand how important the
food aspect of this is until you look
back and see that in the Middle Ages
food was mostly meat and it was spiced
up and if you put time on something
that's moldy you can destroy bacteria
you know time kills bacteria in 60
seconds or so so you have all these
strange foods that basically are heavily
spiced or you know being sanitized by
the herbs and then they even put I think
had guild fielded they had this meatloaf
of birds that they put feathers over the
top of so there's a whole lot of heavy
meat dishes and and we kind of exit that
kind of era of food when John Evelyn was
writing about food and he also read
about horticulture and if you read about
his quote about lettuces he was really
into introducing the salad into the diet
once again so his treatise of
horticulture he has asked to carry as a
part of that mrs. lettuce is a principal
foundation of the universe of try both
salads and it's it has beneficial
influences on morals temperance and
chastity I've never thought about that
one I had a salad but he's fascinating
guide he's got great books and he has
all the tools listed that they had in
that day and then actually in Europe
have started being influenced by North
American foods or South American foods
with the beans etc so this big trade and
a different change and diet to be more a
vegetable so one dimension on this guy
lover in who has a cookbook and he's the
person who's starting French foods that
has the idea of vegetables tasting fresh
not vegetables stood up and cooked
different of soups this is fresh
vegetables with a sauce and it's the
start of French cooking this is an
amazing book and you can get it in
translation
so Jefferson goes to Paris he brings
along Sally to take care of his two
daughters with in James Sally's brother
these were slaves comes over and he has
James apprentice to his caterer and then
he sends it to Chantilly which is a
picture down below to learn to cook in
that kitchen I was amazed their kitchen
is up there you can see the size of it
all of the exquisite pots and technique
this is really top-notch stuff they are
serving kings and queens at this english
castle so this is the kind of food that
Jefferson is going to have and when you
have another picture yeah so James for
instance he learns to make this
beautiful fritter and then he brings it
back to Monticello it continues as the
Belle fritters and it becomes like apple
fritters later it kind of gets a little
rustic after a while but he's got this
this French influence this is really
top-notch beautiful cooking and so this
is the kitchen that Jefferson builds
when he gets back from France and you
can see on the left are two stoves you
got all the best
copper pops the hearth is back there
with a clock jack that's kind of law and
odd little thing in the middle a big
oven on the right he's got this stone
mortar which is amazing and that's made
for making pesto this is a beautiful
kitchen don't to work in so I wanted to
show you this because you can see the
kitchen that we're familiar with the
stew soaps on the Left they allow you to
put charcoal under a pot and have like
low temperature cooking and you can
regulate with grids on top the little
out outlays here this is just to take
Asha way up in the upper left-hand
corner you can see that pavilion and
it's called a pavilion it's the first
structured Jefferson built at Monticello
and that was to live in and downstairs
was the kitchen and it has been kind of
a men's bathroom since the 1940s and
recently we have enough money to
excavate that and bring it back to be
what it what it used to be the
interesting thing is that that pavilion
doesn't match the level of Monticello
house this Monticello has the two
terraces so this is at the end of one
Terrace when he decides to build
Monticello it's
the hillside that he's building on
doesn't doesn't match so he just has the
workers filled the bottom of the
pavilion in with three feet of fill just
fill it up and we'll go on from there
and so the archaeologists then took out
the three feet of fill this winter and
they had 40,000 artifacts in it because
the yards dirt is full of debris and so
they got amazing material and at the
bottom of it they find the original stew
stove foundations and the charcoal from
1808 was in them and so they found other
parts of the whole kitchen so it's very
exciting to know that they actually had
these stew stoves and stuff really early
on and then he builds this big kitchen
to follow and so the idea that this cook
this food is really exquisite and
Jefferson was known to given really
great dinners and siddur so that's the
bouquet garni everybody knows about that
he put a bunch of herbs in soup but it
was a whole series of different kinds
invented by this guy loved bran
so in Jefferson ends up growing all of
these herbs that I mentioned by him so
that's one reason for it here's a list
of herbs that he decides to grow in 1794
so that's pretty inspired so we first
knew all those words and so the enslaved
people have on all of these plants that
they bring as well and Karen has has
done a lot of work on she's passed away
now but she has done a lot of work with
finding these origins of Southern
cuisine so I'll show you Michael Twitty
as well he's just recently released a
book about Southern cuisine he's kiddin
see he's cooking in our kitchen and
David shields does a lot of work very
interesting work on finding sources for
the original plant material and he
actually went to Trinidad recently
because Americans were a group of
enslaved people that had been freed and
hired by the British to fight in the war
of 1812 and in return they got free land
in Trinidad and they brought their seeds
with them and so the upland the red or
plain beard and rice that Jefferson had
has been grown in Trinidad ever since
and so now it's being it's in quarantine
and we'll come back to
Monticello soon so here's some some of
the seeds from they enslave people like
this is um denne or sesame and he has a
nice white flower and then the pods make
these beautiful seeds and Jefferson was
hoping to make oil from this instead of
olive oil because olives didn't grow
very well at Monticello you were lots of
this here's okra the okra plants grow
really tall and huge and they're used to
make soups and he grew it around his
Tomatoes as a barricade here's an
eggplant and it was you know Jefferson
felt that when Martha
cooked the eggplants it tasted like soft
crabs so I think he was pretty
landlocked the West India gherkin is an
amazing thing that came in for the
slaves of the the seeds are extremely
tiny but the plan is so prolific and
this is a really tasty little crunchy
cucumber that doesn't cross pollinate
with their average cucumber so and then
sorghum is a kind of millet and you can
pop it you can rind it you can certain
varieties have that sweets syrup in the
stalk so there's going to be we're gonna
go for that in in our garden because
Jefferson colored guinea corn at the
time and then the peanuts we have the
Carolina African runner peanut that
actually came off of slaves shipped in
1670 and this is profusely prolific with
peanuts I don't know if you know about
peanuts grew any of you seen peanuts
when they pollen are pollinated the the
flower sends a peg into the ground and
that forms the the peanut nut
underground and so when you lift up a
peanut plant it's full of these pegs and
this actually creates a big mat of
peanuts really tiny and they're used
mostly for cooking oil so and then the
Lewis and Clark expedition left
Monticello in 1803 and then went out to
try to find the Pacific and when they
went up this branch of the river they
got up to about here when they met snow
and they built a fort and lived
for until dan april of the next year on
the with the products of the man day and
Arikara and Hidatsa tribes down at the
bottom is the boat that the man dan's
used and on the right is the boat that
Lewis and Clark expedition used so
there's their situation is cold this is
North Dakota and I have a three-month
growing season and so we actually have a
seat exchange and with we got the beans
and corn and sunflowers etc from the
descendants of these tribes to grow at
Monticello once again so this adult
Sabine is amazing it's got one seed
makes like a hundred 20 pods sometimes
on one plant it's it's really
significant they have a legend that one
seed will feed twelve people and it's
like it's really it really comes out
that way when I first got this dad's
bean I had 15 seeds and a 42-foot you
know so I thought what it's going to
happen here but actually each plan was
so prolific you can see that production
so in this short rolling season they get
a lot of food that they can store so
here's the Mandan corn that we grow
they'll on the left is the red clay corn
and then there's white flour corn in the
middle and the red red flower corn in
the center this is interesting because
it's really early Cooper really
historically corn only goes up to 4 or 5
feet tall and the plant tillers out with
the cobs along the bottom of stalks I'm
thinking they don't have raccoons
because but we don't have that issue so
for this corn because it's so tiny it's
right next to the Hidatsa being here I
hand pollinate all the called cobs of
corn just make sure we can get a good
crop here's the Arikara sunflower this
um this grows in cold weather as well so
like they plant it when the ice breaks
up on the Missouri River so for us it's
like March 25th we put the seeds in the
ground and needs 45 degrees soil
temperature and so this sunflower
picture was probably taken like June 1st
or 2nd so they grow really fast in the
cold weather and they're pizza huh sighs
heads your great
so here's the seed exchange this is when
we first started back in 2013 and that's
been it's been a really interesting to
grow these crops and we grew some in the
fall this year too so here's some
Jefferson grew all of these different
climatic region regional plants and so
in his day it was pretty amazing because
Jefferson and the colonists great
basically had spring gardens and fall
gardens they didn't grow summer summer
crops so I hope you visit us at the
garden someday soon and here's my
contact information and then I'll give
you a little plant quiz we had this idea
to show you some plants so okay great
all right can you see ok so we I did
show you this plant it's the stalk is
really big I've got it folded up three
times so does anybody recognize this
it's got these really great pods that
when you open them up all of the seeds
are kind of lined up like a little
bending machine that gorgeous and then
hopefully all these people all left the
Sesame right and that's a really nice
little flower you can see here's some
young pods we had a chef visit who
decided to try to cook the young pods
you can see some seeds here right there
gorgeous okay so that grows really well
for us corn this is the Mandan red
flower corn and the white flour corn
although this is what I got to plant
this is what I got from it interesting
that
didn't get any blue ones but maybe we
just had yellow pollen I don't know but
I wanted to show you that in
relationship to Damon Morgan's Kentucky
butcher corn take things away which is a
corn that we make into hominy and if I
open this one up you can see the
relative size of Europe corn versus what
the Indians were we're producing so this
uh from top to bottom and the Indians
were doing the Mandan had eight hundred
acres of their crop and the tools that
they used the garden with was so this is
a antler
they would tie an antler to a stick and
they also the other pole was made of a
scapula from the Buffalo eight hundred
acres and then they figured out how to
cash the food and so then when visitors
and my explorers from from Canada from
the British the Spanish alright at that
place on the Missouri they had plenty to
to sell and they so these Indians had
all the latest in cooking pots calico
pins and needles they were very sharp
people I got here some recognize these
little fuzzies chestnuts this is this is
cotton so I did see this one out in your
garden here this is the red foliated
white cotton and you can see the seeds
are right here this is a her suitum
cotton which means you know the sticky
seed you know the hirsute name it means
it's got this fuzz to it this is the
green lint cotton did you know there was
Manhattan's and this is a also sticky
seed this is probably early ins green
and then we have this one here this is
man Keene cotton and it's written about
in Jefferson's books as a yellow cotton
and made the cloth actually became
called nankeen from this and then I have
this cotton here you can see the seeds
are slipping out easily so this is C
Island Brown cotton and this is I
believe a barbadensis a variety instead
of here sue them isn't that cool now the
thing about this is that all of these
Cotton's with sticky seeds grow better
in Virginia and so Jefferson needs a gym
to take the seeds out because it takes
so much time to pull this apart so he
gets the cotton gin
he's Secretary of State when in also
running the Patent Office we Neal I
Whitney sins and plans for the cotton
gin and he says is this really a dream
or is you really have this machine I
really need like two of these so the gym
is saw blades that will tear up the
cotton off the seed if you showed
somebody a gin with this kind of cotton
they would they would die because
they're cutting this the fibers up the
the whole thing is that you want the
longest fiber you can get and to be able
to straighten it out and then twist it
into thread and sew the Ecuadorians have
a cotton that's very long fiber about
four inches long and they just remove
the seeds by hand and then straighten it
out why hacking it with a stick on a
pillow and that's really beautiful long
thread that they can make from there and
like Egyptian cotton is that barbed
identity as well seceded so that's
pretty fascinating
I'll show you this crazy little thing
recognize these these are quite mature
they remember this the gherkin yeah I'll
cut it in half you can see how big these
seeds are in here how many seeds really
prolific look at all those seeds each
seed is an entire plant cut this one
this way
fewer seeds when it's smaller but still
what you want to do is is get it when
it's tiny like like this big okay so I
just wanted to show you the gherkins we
just harvested them proceeded recently
they're all gone yeah the whole thing is
edible and so we know it's fun with kids
because it's all prickly can you eat
that prickly thing so here's a couple of
pods from our friend the okra so I'll
show you what they look like inside when
they're this size they are pretty
fibrous so you can see the seeds in here
when they're smaller about this size
then we eat them otherwise we save them
for seeds and for Christmas decorations
I had two different varieties of this
anybody recognize this point this is a
dried one this is a dried artichoke use
this for Christmas as well the
artichokes we grow don't have very good
flavor and this is really fun Jefferson
called this the most minutest board ever
seen and he sends it to his
grandchildren it's the Tennessee
spinning board so you can grow toys and
garden so who knew that Jefferson had a
sense of humor so I'll show you this
this is gonna be hard for you to figure
out the most important part is right
here at the top right here take this off
crush it and what do you have there
let us seed so I don't know how many of
you've seen let us go to seed well we in
fact here's all the seeds down here
shake it out
we we cut the heads off usually shorter
than this like about here dry the heads
in the greenhouse in a dry greenhouse
and then crush them through sips to get
the seeds out and what's interesting is
the ants love lettuce seed too and so if
we're in a rush we can just pick up the
newspaper and underneath will be cute
little piles of lettuce seed already
clean
we just scoop it up
I'll show you this plant here because
it's one side there's another side
anybody recognize this tobacco so we
grow that arena Kota backhoe which is
what Jefferson would have had came from
Surinam there's great stories if you
read a book by a prevent from the 1600s
the first book by a woman author
describing the plight of slaves and it
became a stage play in the Victorian era
it's all about a renico who was a slave
who he was actually a prince to marry
the princess and he sold as a slave and
then he and his wife-to-be have a pact
that they're gonna kill each other
because they can't well his wife is
actually taken by his dad really bad
stuff happened so his last words is all
I want before I die
is to smoke pipe before in a cook
tobacco so it's pretty good but um this
is being dried now and what I really
liked is this fall was that he was such
a ladybug factory you can see some
evidence of bugs here the we had a pits
galore and then the aphids all attracted
ladybugs and all kinds of beneficial
insects that were using though the
honeydew and it was it's amazing how
many ladybugs we have in the garden
because this happened on our sorghum
last year and so we had no reason to
remove them so we just let them go when
he had a
lady ladybug larvae over six inches or
somes
hull patch it was just loaded and a
tobacco farmer came and I said you know
usually I wash all these leaves off
because of all this stuff he says no one
else does so just so now I'll show you a
couple of tools and then I'll be I'll be
done I think here's one special tool
that I was telling you about
right here how many of you have symbols
today that's very impressive
so in Jefferson's day every woman would
have had it everywhere in child would
have a symbol and sometimes you and I'll
show you this beautiful thing that got
recently and I saw this on one of your
posters in the hallway so does anybody
know what this tool is it's it's a
string line so we use the string lines
for everything in the garden and I use a
compass with a string line to make sure
everything is parallel and then
sometimes you treasuring sticks to
measure out the plants sometimes use my
feet and so this I love this thing but
this is actually 1800s something a
little less extreme but I wanted to show
you that because that's what Jefferson
you know something like that's what
Jefferson had and this is what his
Indian neighbors were using compare the
different ways of gardening it's just
you know it really is phenomenal so
thank you very much for putting up with
life we do so many things are you
talking about bugs are you talking about
poorly yeah or legged mammals so we have
an electric fence we put up every night
for deer and other we have some
woodchucks that are just monsters we put
up a fence every night take it down
every morning we have a three dogs so
you let out to get the little animals
raccoons and stuff you had a beautiful
baby raccoon treed last year is really
cute and
some Fox and we have other things skunks
you know a lot of animals because we're
right in woods basically a lot of birds
the crows are really obnoxious so we put
cages over any emerging cotton having
corn or beans because they'll pull them
right out so yeah we have to and we let
him get up to a good height before we
take the cage off other methods sort of
period no you know I don't know what his
crow problem might have been but he had
a paling fence which means ribbon boards
and have been 12 feet high around the
whole garden including the fruit garden
so it was like almost a mile-long fence
and the boards were close enough so he
said so what hair wouldn't go through so
we rabbit wouldn't go through before he
had the fence built Martha would write
to him saying that the pigs are trashing
the garden so they they had animal
problems beyond ours
Janina Oh up here I was curious
one of your earlier slides said that he
had 15 types of broccoli that's the
problem have you been able to find or
grow those kinds are seen them or know
any extra information I'm happy to send
you an email instead but I'll show you
the list that I have for broccoli
okay idea we do grow Torah starts
shining but we grow the white broccoli
the early purple we've grown different
kinds of green and I just sort of label
them as Roman or green or whatever and
the black broccoli down there thank you
so much we really enjoyed it up here
[Music]
tomato we have the pomme d'amore yes and
it grows beautifully for us so that's C
that's a tricky question because and
Jefferson's day well I'll show you what
he says about tomato it stomata Spanish
tomahto bigger than the other ones and
the dwarf damata that runs around the
ground like a weed so that's all he's
got to say here's tomahto so we know
that he goes to Williamsburg and meets
his family physician is dr. John Disick
Kyra who I'm probably pronouncing his
name wrong but he's working at
Williamsburg and he advocates eating
tomato everyday for eternal health
that's been change over time hasn't it
and so we know that's in the earliest of
the 1760s or so and in 1781 and this
notes on the state of Virginia Jefferson
lists tomatoes along with most melons
and passionfruit and everything else so
we know the tomato is you know just
being cultivated in Virginia without
much fanfare so but this is all he says
because of that issue of not having
variety means so we grow all kinds of
tomatoes and basically the cost of ludo
Genovese Augusto de Catanese because
Italy has its regionality and has a
tomato ride for each region and they've
been in in cultivation since the 1500s
the Medici family had tomatoes
it became the food of the peasant so I
descried to cry to grow things that grow
well for
and this year we grew Cherokee purple
tomatoes which did not grow very well at
all and it wasn't from seeds that we had
saved over time so I'm going to save
some seeds and see if they'll grow
better next year but that's a modern
1990 tomato and you know it's just it's
not suited oh this lady had a question
forever because this is so amazing
there are some there's some references
there's some guy named Edwin Ruffin who
I was reading and he was talking about
manuring and crop rotation so that's a
great question and you know be
interesting to see if any of Jefferson's
information debt dispersed to his
neighbor's some he had he did have his
friend George divers at Farmington who's
down in in Charlottesville we're up hill
we're at 800 feet off Charles Ville
George had his farm and Jefferson would
send some of his seeds to George as a
plan-b like in case mine fail you'll
have the plant and they had a pecan test
which is always touted to all the kids
who had the first dish appease and won
and then that person would give a big
dinner and one apiece and so one year
Jefferson's peas came in first but he
says to Martha George best loves giving
a dinner we're not going to tell him our
peas came in first so but that's a great
question as something I really should
look into yeah and so you had a question
so it'd be really great if trees could
persist 250 years but you know but we
have we have records of what they are
and so we reintroduced those trees and
we have you know put them in the right
spots and one interesting thing is that
he has a really large leaf magnolias I
think it's macrophylla
and he's got it on the you know the
house and there's the garden the flower
garden and then the slope this goal we
called the upper Grove he's got them
sighted there and I should should take
in a picture but um
where they're cited then they're facing
its the north facing here and then the
West when the Sun sinks in the West here
the north side of that tree trunk is
frozen and then when the West sunshine
hits the trunk in the wintertime it
splits it and so all of the magnolias
have these splits in the trunk and then
they die we cut them off and then they
come back up so they've been there over
and over again but it's a terrible
location but we put it in that way yeah
it gets things from from Andre from in
Paris a number of things then those are
written down to I'm really not a tree
expert I spend a lot of time yeah well
it's we have this Barden Ambassador
Program with Master Gardeners from ten
to two who answer the question that
everybody asks is like what happens to
all the vegetables and I really you know
that's great it takes all that weight
off of me so then when they have a
really cool question they send them over
and I get to talk to them and I can
mention something like did you know this
is where sesame is or if we're just
somewhere and somebody's poking around
and saying that looks like a and then
they get lost you say well that's
actually a pumpkin that's actually a
plant and then you can kind of go from
there so I really do try to help people
along when they're when they look
interested in what they're seeing this
has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu